200 years ago with the only reason with
continues on our heads cut off allowing
the hoi polloi in no it's fantastic I'm
never going to get on a painter of the
wall the only thing I'm worried
concerned I might be up there with a
wire brush in the couple of hours
is quite athletic here doesn't it I mean
it although so what is it about gaming
rooms that we love so much violence is a
very heady mix but it's an extraordinary
mix I think one of the reasons one of
the main reasons is that is the
attention to detail on the storytelling
on this it doesn't it doesn't patronize
it expects you to be grown up and not
just if you know the bad guys aren't
wearing the black hats from the white
guys aren't wearing a white hat it's a
it's constantly surprises you and
constantly cosas con su cara para from
under yon i think i think audiences not
that I love it when i'm reading the
magna oh my god i was expecting that but
it's extraordinary i'm gonna comment and
it's fantastic thing to be part of and
you know there's nothing like this has
ever going to come along again you might
have fantastic storytelling well not not
none of this kind of variety I'm with
this you know level of intricate weird
wonderful extraordinary carry that many
shows that have the water cooling my
people did you see I know like a red
wedding and all sorts of stuff above a
black eye no it's not absolutely not and
that's what we people home of I mean you
know these trailers for a big Hollywood
movies like the entire movies in the
trailer but the point going to see it
where is this thing and you know credit
of the fans a lot of them know what's
coming up and they don't say anything
and they allow you know a lil the
Minster to kind of enjoy it and sprint
and those people are sitting in one
endless over going you weren't expecting
that way and it's a Joey it's a
fantastic it's a growth experience I
don't allow see when you get the scrip
do you flip the ends and makes oil spill
it
no i don't i know i don't i know i don't
just no no no no i think they usually
and picture of the email of i would
never go to the search engine gave you
dad yeah yeah yeah it's just a small
headstone on the email what didn't they
tell me no no it's so far so good I'm
just a bit better